Eh bien bonsoir les amis et bienvenue en Abitibi
région située à quatre heures de route de Outaouais, là où on avait fait du rafting la dernière fois on est arrivé.
On est arrivé y quoi? Y'a deux heures on a eu le temps de manger, de boire un café
de se changer, nous sommes en short.
Cet après midi au programme, c'est du vélo dans les montagnes de l'Abitibi.
Avec le rafting et tout ce qu'on a fait les jours d'avant, je commence à être un peu fatigué
Euh mais bon on va tout donner pour le VTT c'est la dernière activité crevante.
Bref j'ai fixé les GoPro partout comme pour le rafting et puis je vous dis à tout de suite sur mon bike.
♫ Musique ♫
Ok les amis, après cette petite bière on a eu le temps se laver, ça fait 48 heures mon gars, c'était l'un des plus beaux moments de ma vie.
On s'est inspecté pour voir si on avait des tiques parce qu'on avait pas eu le temps de faire dans la vidéo d'avant.
On est un peu crevé mais c'est cool parce que là on va un peu de chillé ici
Alors je vous explique est vite fait ce que c'est le Val-d'Or, c'est la ville dans laquelle on est
donc c'est une ville située en Abitibi et qui vit essentiellement de l'exploitation minière donc c'est essentiellement des mines qui exploite l'or
et en fait derrière moi c'est une maison typique qui a été construite dans les années 1920 pour les mineurs ceux qu'allaient miner l'or
ils avaient le droit d'avoir une maison comme ça uniquement s'ils étaient en couple
donc quand t'étais beau gosse t'étais très très avantagé à l'époque.
Ah ce qu'il y a à savoir aujourd'hui c'est que dans ces maisons là il y a des familles qui vivent encore
et surtout il y a encore énormément de gens qui travaillent dans la mine dans la ville.
Par exemple, les trois personnes avec qui on a fait du vélo tout à l'heure, les trois travaillent dans la mine
Alors pas dans la même, il y en a plusieurs comme j'ai dis mais les trois vont bosser dans une mine, ils ont différents postes etc
et c'est assez fou quoi !
Encore aujourd'hui ça fait presque.. bah ça fait 100 piges presque qui vivent de l'exploitation minière quoi.
Donc nous on dort dans une auberge qui est juste à côté qui a pas cette tête là mais qu'est quand même très charmante
et demain on va avoir la chance d'aller dans une mine !
Alors il y aura pas de mineurs à côté de nous, en fait c'est plus utilisé et puis voilà on a hâte.
♫ Musique ♫
Les amis il est maintenant temps, après cette bonne bière et ce bon dîner, on va aller à la fête foraine du Val-d'Or.
Voilà !
[Voix de forain] Et c'est parti bien sûr !
J'pourrais faire ma voix de forains pendant toute.. toute la fin de la vidéo, c'est magnifique !
Y a un problème, y a Passe-Partout qui veut m'amener à la prochaine épreuve sauf je suis pas dans Fort Boyard
Les amis nous sommes actuellement actuellement dans la grande roue de la fête foraine du Val-d'Or en Abitibi
Avec ces gens qui m'ont totalement suivi !
*Rire de Squeezie*
La fille québécoise : C'est mal attaché des fois
*Regarde du malaise*
Écouté c'était hyper enrichissant de vous rencontrez, ce soir, je pensais pas qu'il y aurait autant de gens qui me reconnaîtrai à la fête foraine
Vous avez tous été cool, vous m'avez même offert des peluches, des trucs..
C'est..c'est hyper touchant, mille mercis !
On est prêt pour visiter la mine demain et on va s'endormir sur de belles notes à demain
Vous dites à demain ?
- À demain !
- Au top !
♫ Musique ♫
- Les amis avez-vous bien dormi ? Nous, oui.
Il est 9 heures du matin, nous sommes avec Guy Édouard, enchanté Guy Édouard ça va ?
- Bonjour, enchanté bienvenus
- Merci beaucoup
On est sur le site de la cité de l'or.
On y va tout de suite? On doit s'équiper avant je crois? Parce qu'il va faire 8°C là dessus
Donc on.. (bégaie)Tu nous a prévu des p'tits..
- Un survêtement, un casque, un ceinturon et tout et après ça on se prépare pour la descente
Génial on va ressembler Indiana Jones mon gars c'est parti !
Les amis, on est dans la pièce on va pouvoir se changer
On va mettre une tenue comme ça et on va descendre
Un fonçage de galerie*
*Rire*
C'est comme ça qu'ils récoltaient la roche il avait des foreuses qui pèsent jusqu'à 75 kg tu nous a dis ?
75 kg ça et des fois ils devaient monter des échelles avec ça sur le dos, les mecs c'était totalement des surhommes
Et, peut-être ça peut être intéressant de montrer, la salle à manger des mineurs hyper spacieuse 5 étoiles mon gars.
Et voilà on a tous vu !
*Rires*
Micro-ondes de l'époque n'est ce pas
Donc ça aussi c'est aussi le refuge, c'est à dire qu'en cas de problème un incendie donc ça fait beaucoup de fumée etc
ils viennent se réfugier ici, il y a un téléphone pour contacter la surface et ce qui est dangereux c'est que dans une mine
Ils travaillaient toujours par deux, pourquoi ?
Parce qu'il y a énormément de bruit et du coup si tu as un pépin, t'as une petite galère, tu t'es blessé ou quoi
tu peux pas appeler à l'aide, on ne t'entendra pas
Donc ils bossent par deux et quand le matin, un mec a la gueule de bois et décide de faire une petite pièce d'une heure
Et ben son pote est seul dans la mine donc c'est assez dangereux donc morale de l'histoire ne pas boire d'alcool avant de travailler
avant tout court d'ailleurs faut pas boire de l'alcool tout oourt
Regardez on est devant un wagon que les mineurs utilisés, ça c'est les premiers wagons dans les années 30
ils le poussé à la force de leurs bras et ensuite ils devaient les décharger à l'aide d'une manivelle
tout était vraiment manuel 5 10 ans plus tard
5-10 ans plus tard
Ça avait déjà évolué, il y avait un moteur un gros moteur, regarde ça il est juste en face.
Alors faut dire que ça à la base c'était en plein milieu des couloirs, ce n'était pas du tout dans un coin comme ça
Et ici on a un moteur électrique
Bien sûr type port USB C on connaît bien, pour charger ton iPhone
ça pouvait transporter quatre wagons environ de.. comme ceux comme celui-ci mec rempli de roche ça fait un maximum de roche.
Pour vous donner une idée dans cette mine la valeur change selon la concentration de l'or des roches dans les mines
et dans cette mine là, elle était particulièrement riche car il fallait 5 tonnes de roche pour avoir 32 grammes d'or, ce qui fait une once de gars
Donc il y a d'autres mines ça.. il faut 10 tonnes 20, 30 même des fois
Donc cette mine était particulièrement très très très efficace
Attention
imaginez ce son x40 dans vos oreilles
*Son enregistré du wagon à moteur*
C'est fini on peut.. On peut respirer ?
Ah !
Mec moi je déteste les bruits au fort et sourd, j'ai un problème avec ça j'aurais jamais pu travailler dans une mine, c'est fou
T'imagine ça +40 mec plus tes pote avec leurs fourreuses à côté, c'est terrible mon gars
Aujourd'hui mec on ferait une journée dans une mine on aurait l'impression d'être..
de mourir !
Lui il faisait ça pendant des années donc c'est hyper respectable, les mineurs vous déchirez, si vous êtes mineurs vous déchirez
*Rires*
♫ Musique ♫
Les amis bienvenue en Kinawit ! C'est ici que va se terminer notre séjour au Canada, t'es triste Clément ?
Kinawit ça veut dire : Tous pour tous
Pourquoi ça veut dire pour tous ? Parce que c'est un centre communautaire et associatif qui a été créée pour rassembler les autochtones
Les autochtones sont les amérindiens.
D'ailleurs on en a vu quelques-uns à la fête foraine hier soir
En fait il n'y en a pas en France, il y en a très peu en France des amérindiens
Ce qui est logique parce que c'est des amérindiens du coup
*Rires*
On va se reposer là, vous voyez un tipi là-bas habitat traditionnel des amérindiens
Ça c'est un véhicule typique amérindiens aussi
Ça se voit que c'est la fin du voyage, le nombre de conneries qu'on dise c'est assez fou
Bah voilà écoute mec ça est très reposant on va être en pleine nature
On va dormir dans un tipi une nouvelle fois, c'est tout ce qu'on veut pour terminer ce voyage ça va être très reposant
Tu me suis Clément? C'est parti dans ton 'mind' et dans tes jambes.
La fatigue est là hein ?
La fatigue est là hein ? Oh p*tain mec, là on a vraiment envie de dormir
♫ Musique ♫
Les amis c'est la fin de cette troisième et dernière vidéo au Canada
On n'aura vécu beaucoup de choses très positives, on a pu rencontrer des gens, on a pu découvrir des régions que je n'aurais jamais découvert
Euh.. autrement..
On a vu la ville, on a vu la campagne, on a fait des sports extrêmes, on a vu Nabil [Aiekillu]
On a rencontré Frédéric, Philippe, Kevin, Serge, André..
Oh p*tain de moustique ! Oh sa mère !
Mec c'est.. allume la lumière de seconde
Moustique Land
Bref on a fait de très très belles rencontres durant tout le voyage que ce soit des gens parmi vous
ou les gens qui nous ont aidé à vivre ces moments merveilleux, qu'ils nous ont guidé finalement à travers le Canada
En tout cas merci d'avoir suivi les vidéos, je sais pas ça vous a plu parce que je les publie que dans un mois
Mais j'espère que oui !
Si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à les aimer toutes, toutes comme ça d'affilé clac clac clac
Merci Clément d'avoir accompagné pendant ce voyage
Merci mon bro
Merci à tous et à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo
Au revoir
♫ Musique ♫
Cliquez au milieu pour voir la vidéo précedente!
*Messages des traducteurs* : N'oubliez pas le petit pouce bleu et n'hésitez pas à aller regarder d'autre de ses vidéos !
Sous-titre par: Lunday (Correction et structuration), Timcraft0, AmirLeThug et Willipro123Gaming (Les dialogues)